Speaker 1: I got a voicemail from an
astrologist. Now, I don't believe in any
of this stuff, but here is an astrologist
explaining how Donald Trump still has 35%
approval. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hello, David. I'm
astrologer. I've been on a TV show.
Speaker 1: A similar astrologer,
not an astrologist. Sorry, but.
Speaker 3: Dragon's Den is Donald
Trump's astrology chart years ago. I'm pretty
accurate. Anyways, in your video, Trump approval
plunges to lowest in year. You were scared that
still 34% approve of him. Yeah. Just what is in
astrology? There's 30 degrees in each sign and ten
degrees of them are always in what's called cusp.
Half of one sign, half of another and 30% of the
calendar isn't cast. 30% of Trump supporters are.
Trump as soon as they're all cuffed, I guarantee
you they're all before and around the 20/21,
two or three days in between the 21st of
the month. That's how you that's how 33%
of the people still believe in Trump because
astrology, serious geology charts, they're
fooled by it. They're there half of one side,
half of another. And they're confused. They're
built in conflict. That's how it works. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I don't believe in any of that.
Astrology is just not scientific. Even put aside
the concept of people's personalities and lives
being influenced by the position of planets
when they were born. Most of the astrology
charts aren't even actually accurate for the
time that we were born. So like at its face,
it doesn't make any sense. But I always
love hearing an interesting voicemail and
so I appreciate it nonetheless, even though
I don't believe in any of it. We have a great
bonus show for you today. We are going to talk
about Hurricane Ian. We are going to talk about
Edward Snowden getting Russian citizenship from
Vladimir Putin. And we will talk about the latest
in the Matt Gaetz investigation. Charges
likely not forthcoming. Not forthcoming.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money. Everybody else who makes money to
fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1:
All of those stories on two days bonus show. Sign
up at join pack mint.com to get instant access.